hey what is up guys my name is Chen and
welcome back to my OpenGL series so last
time and in fact over the last few
episodes we've been abstracting all of
our opengl cart away into classes so
that we can deal with them a little bit
more easily when it actually comes time
to writing real graphics code and today
we're gonna continue that journey with
shaders so we've done like vertex
buffers and vertex arrays and like
vertex buffer lay house and all that
kind of stuff and now the next step is
gonna be shaders so let's take a look at
how we can actually extract shaders well
first of all let's just talk about so
the way that I'm gonna structure this
right now is in in a simple way because
shaders when it comes to shaders and if
you guys don't know what a shader is by
the way definitely check out the video
that I made about shaders but shaders
are an incredibly complex topic and
shaders are very very important to
graphics programming or any kind of
rendering right and so because of that
there tends to be like a tendency to
actually make a rather complicated
system that is both easy to use but also
extremely powerful
so in games and game engines typically
it's very common to have a custom
shading language which then compiles
into shader code for the each kind of
rendering API or platform and also is
somewhat kind of controllable and
extensible through the code at runtime
meaning that it's very common for games
to actually generate new shaders and
then have them be used for rendering
while the game is actually running or
while the game is loading or something
like that right shader generation and
shader kind of creation on the fly is
something that's very very common and in
general the whole like rabbit hole of
let's write a shader system for our
engine like tends to be such a massive
topic and we're definitely not even
going to scratch the surface today or in
distance higher OpenGL series because
it's irrelevant quite frankly to actual
OpenGL rendering when we think about
shaders in OpenGL like there's nothing
to it you just write text in a file or
as a string and you're done like there's
no real need for any of this stuff that
I just described that kind of stuff is
typically used by an actual game
engine right and we're not talking about
about that in this series this is just
about OpenGL later on when I make the
game engine series we will definitely
talk about that stuff and will
definitely implement a way more
complicated shader and material system
and all that in that serious so I just
want to just want to be on the same page
as everyone else here as to what we're
actually trying to achieve today because
by no means am I trying to rate trying
to write a crazy shader system or
anything like that right here all I'm
doing today is I want to basically take
all of the OpenGL shader code that we've
written abstract that out behind an API
that's really easy to use understand and
keeps our actual kind of user or client
side code really concise so that when it
comes time to do really crazy things
with graphics in this series it's
actually going to be easy for you to
read the actual code because it's gonna
be high-level and Telly conceptual and
not like you know GL uniform matrix 4fv
or whatever the function names might be
right it's gonna be very simple to deal
with hopefully at least that's my goal
for this so that being said what is it
that we actually need to need to
abstract in our shader code right well
what it is it whoa we haven't done
anything particularly too crazy I mean
we're loading a shader from a file based
on the source code that I'm reading
right now and we're rendering it and I
think it might have a uniform or
something like that that we're setting
yeah what's that we're setting a uniform
for EFI with the color I think of our
yes with the color of our rectangle or
out square that's all that we're doing
but in general what does the shaders
need well first of all we want to be
able to basically pass in a file or a
string and have that be compiled as a
shader so that's kind of step one we
want to be able to bind and unbind the
shader step two and step three is we
want to be able to set the uniforms all
the different uniforms for the shader
okay that's probably if for something
that we're looking at right now I mean
like reading back attributes reading
back like being able to load in a shader
and then ask the shader hey what
uniforms do you actually have and what
types are they all that is something
that would be incredibly useful but
again that probably falls more into a
shader system for a game engine and that
would actually require pausing the
shader source code and all that this way
out of scope is going to take way too
long
not something I'm interested in right
now anyway for this series I mean but
yeah I mean we just want to be able to
create shaders bind them for use and
also set uniforms that's it
so let's dive in and start refactoring
the source code so that we can do all of
that okay so step one under source let's
add a new item I'm going to add a header
file it's going to be called shader and
I'm going to do the same thing for a CPP
file okay
CPP file of course is going to include
the header file and let's go back to the
header file and start editing out so
class shader we're just going to have a
few Pub private and public things here
we'll have a constructor which takes in
a Const SCD string file name now what I
did do last time or not last time but in
the actual shared or a episode what I
actually ended up doing was inside
application I did actually make it so
that we could write our shader in one
file because I find it very annoying
having to deal with two files so you can
see that over here we actually have a
single file with two kind of sections
shader fragment and shadow vertex so
that's very important that also means
that we don't need to be able to take in
kind of well we don't need to take in
two different files we can just take in
the file path and everything will be ok
so file path we're going to have a
destructor we're going to have bind
which is going to be a constant function
and unbind now of course with opengl we
kind of bind vertex arrays and we bind
vertex buffers and we bind like index
buffers or textures or all that stuff
but with shader programs is called gel
use program now since we're making this
API though we're going to be consistent
and we're gonna call bind for everything
so this is gonna be bind and then we're
gonna have unbind and that is of course
consistent with things like our vertex
buffer which also have a bind and unbind
all right and then finally I want to be
able to also set uniforms now there are
so many of these and again I'm not
trying to create a complicated shader
system so I don't want to make something
that's templated and then has to
actually deal with its own kind of
things if I was writing this as actual
kind of code for my engine or something
like that I would definitely just
probably have a set value or set uniform
function that was kind of 10
flattered and not even templated but
also like in a more complicated shader
system you would actually just pause the
trader source code to work out what type
a uniform variable was and by doing that
you can validate kind of what goes into
it and also design an API so that you
can just have set value and all you need
is the name and the value and it will
automatically set the right data and all
of that something whether I think I
talked about in the game engine series
but for now we're just trying to keep
this code really straightforward really
simple so that again when we actually
get into making things in OpenGL it's
gonna be easy to read and people won't
have to be like wow this is such a
complicated system why I built something
like that or I doesn't make any sense
for this so just keep that in mind so
we're gonna have like a set uniform for
F or something like that which is just
gonna mimic our initial line and then
we'll add the other ones as we go along
so this of course is going to have to
have a Const STD string name and then a
float and then for floats for the value
so we'll just have v-0 v1 if I had a
maths library which we need to get on to
I would probably just use that here like
I mean like a vector for okay so there
we go
and then I think that's pretty much it
so in terms of private what we need here
is an unsigned int renderer ID and then
we're also going to have some kind of
caching system in a minute for uniforms
and you'll find out why in a minute I'll
also have a private function down here
which is going to be an unsigned and I
think get uniform location and it's
going to take in a contest city string
name as well that's going to be used to
retrieve our OpenGL uniform locations
all right right click here and then
using using visual cysts I'll create
method implementations I'm also going to
include string here because it's getting
a little bit sad at me okay cool so back
over here let's start filling all this
stuff out now for debug purposes I'm at
I am actually going to also save that
file path just so that we can print out
like what share what file the shader
belongs to if we need to so I'll just
set that up here and file path file path
I'm also going to assign renderer ID to
0 and then I'm going to write a function
called compile a shader and this is just
going to be another private function
here void compile
shada we might want to return false or
something I might actually make this a
boolean and then compile shader let's go
over here make it just beneath the
destructor and then I'll call it
compiled shader of course shader and
it's actually a board alright cool
so compile shader if we go back to our
application code we've already written
all this code we're just refactoring it
so here's the Creator code that already
has a better shader a fragment shader
which is cool I'm just going to take all
this and in fact this entire function
copy it I'm going to put it here now I
could leave it as static because it's
really not going to change but I will
reflect vary in a minute to be an actual
member and then this I think is our
compiled shader function which I tried
to make here but obviously I forgot that
I actually had it here and then this is
our path shader which just figures that
stuff out so really I'm just copying
everything from our actual main
application file into here and then
Wayne shader program sources well
trainer program source might just be a
struct that I actually make up here in
this class rather than have it in the
header file because I only want it
accessible here if we scroll up we're
going to have to steal some of these
includes as well so let's pop them down
here and we definitely need the renderer
as well ok cool so that looks pretty
good
of course let's clean this up now so we
have PA's Raider which I'm gonna make
all of these methods so we're gonna have
passed shader we don't need the file
path because we have that on the member
although I might pass that in anyway
compile so this doesn't all need to be
static anymore
that looks good career chatter as well
will not make - static and we'll make it
a member shada
like that and this is probably a bit big
let me make it a bit smaller
hopefully you guys can still see
compiled shader becomes a member as well
ok that looks pretty good sorry let's
stop making these actual functions so we
have on my Mac them up here
unsigned int create shader and then we
also have compiled shader which is what
I tried to make but that returns an int
so let's edit that yeah in fact I'm
going back on my whole original plan
here and actually just making it match
what I had an application because I
forgot I had half of that courage let's
copy that as well for Paz shader just
get rid of the shader thing all right
cool
so that's what our API kind of looks
like right now and let's get rid of this
and this is okay so we're going to I
guess because we've actually got shader
program source here we kind of do need
to have that there so I'm just gonna
again keep it simple and move this
shader program source over here cool all
right that looks pretty good
and of course we're getting errors here
but that's fine okay so now we've
actually converted this code to be
inside this file instead of inside
application so let's remove it from
application and now all we really need
to do is actually make it work so the
first thing that we really need to do is
inside our shader source code in the
constructor we're just going to set m
renderer ID to be compile or sorry what
is it
so the first thing we do is we've passed
the trader let's go back to application
actually see what it's doing
so when it comes to a shader we're doing
all of this basically so these two lines
are what we need so we get a source and
then M render ID is what this is and
that becomes creator okay and then of
course instead of this file path we're
gonna have file path like that so we're
really just maintaining this file path
here as a member just for debugging
purposes okay in the destructor I'm
gonna call gel call Jill delete program
and then this is going to be our and
renderer ID now this is really only
relevant if the renderer IDs isn't zero
so if it's actually successful in
creating it that all of this looks
pretty good I think bind and unbind of
course is just gonna be jail for jail
bind Jill use program M renderer ID and
then unbind is going to use zero
youth program zero say uniform for F so
if we go back to our application we can
kind of well we can see what it is gel
uniform for F so G L call jail uniform
for F now what we actually need here is
the location of the uniform so we need a
way to get a location of the uniform and
then V 0 V 1 V 2 V 3 ok and that's where
get uniform location comes in which is
just this code here so GL call get
uniform location and then the name dot C
string and shader is M renderer ID just
like that ok cool so what we need to do
here is actually assign this so unsigned
int location equals G okay uniform
location if locations negative one it
means that we don't actually have it now
we could just make this code assert here
but sometimes it's quite valid for us to
actually have negative one as a shader
location so if we have a uniform in our
shader for example and it's being used
somewhere but we comment that line out
or we declare a uniform but we just
don't use it yet or for whatever reason
then that's going to mean that it gets
stripped which means that we don't have
that uniform in the shader at all and
this is going to give us negative one
but that might like we still want our
shader to work like normal because we
might have intentionally just declared a
uniform but not used it so that's why I
don't want to assert here but we may
want to print some kind of message here
being like you know warning uniform and
then name doesn't exist just in case we
have a rendering error so that we can
see that and then we'll also return that
location now this is going to become get
uniform location name and this is sorry
get uniform location like that so our
our actual function that looks pretty
good just make sure you call this V 2
and V 3 and not F for some reason don't
wait why did that just switched halfway
through
they just answer value in our in our
case alright cool so that was pretty
good now there is an issue that will
address in a minute with the get your
form location thing but otherwise I
think that's pretty decent our code
should work so let's actually go back to
application and hopefully our code does
work I'm actually gonna close everything
but that okay so this stuff is going to
just become let's actually include
shader at the top first of all included
shader H and then down down over here
shader shader and we'll take in this
path and then we'll do shaded up bind
then we can just leave it bound probably
and then instead of this location and
whatever we're trying to set that
variable this just kind of becomes
shader dot set uniform for F the name
which is u underscore color and then the
actual values which is this thing yeah
and then I believe so you can see how
much code that reduces it's nice and
simple now use program zero is just
shaded or on bond with bind like the
buffers we could probably address that
in a minute as well we don't actually
all we do have it next but we can do
that in a minute
Jill use program shader of course is
just shaded aligned and this again which
is shaded dot set uniform for F you
color and then that okay so you can see
how much that simplified out code and
then finally we don't need to delete it
at all because when we actually reach
the entered the scope it will be deleted
by the destructor of shader and yeah so
with this I don't know why I've still
got this but Sheila ray buff but that's
just VB dot on bind and then that's just
IB unbind so we might as well fix that
now just on binding everything basically
I might just leave that like that okay
cool
so there we go looks pretty good let's
just hit at five or run this and see
what happens okay so it looks pretty
good we get the same kind of rectangle
and the colors working so everything
looks fine so let's talk about this
little problem that we have so it's not
really like a huge issue or anything but
in shader bill cpp what we actually have
here is inside this game form location
every time we set this uniform we
actually retrieve the location again and
again and again and that's not
particularly fast what we actually want
to do with this
is cash it so that we've only really
retrieve it the first time in there
that's it we're done and we can do that
really really easily we just go back to
shader by age I will include something
called an unordered map which is really
just a hash map or a hash table and then
I'm just going to make STD unordered map
STD string to unsigned int and call this
our location cache or specifically our
uniform location cache I should say and
then all I'm going to do here is the
first thing I want to do is check to see
if the uniform location cache actually
contains the name so if this doesn't
equal M uniform location cache and we'll
simply return and if an M uniform
location cache and then the name
otherwise we'll go ahead and retrieve
the location and if it actually doesn't
equal negative one then we can actually
cache it I mean technically speaking we
we don't really need like we could cache
it ever even if it is negative one it's
not like it's going to change whether or
not uniform exists until we actually
recompile the shader with potentially
new code so this isn't literally need to
be an allison fact i might remove this
from else and just add it regardless so
we're actually adding that location
there and that way if i just put a
breakpoint here so that we can verify
that works properly the first time that
i run this code we should of course
result in a cache miss here and actually
retrieve the location properly you can
see if the location is zero which is a
valid location and then the second time
if I hit f5 that we actually go here we
should just return this without having
to do the GL gate uniform location you
can see that that works okay so of
course we shouldn't see any difference
visually but that should provide us with
a nice whole performance boost
especially when we start having a lot of
uniforms in our shadows anyway I hope
you guys enjoyed this video that's
pretty much all there is to it as always
you can help support the series by going
to patron or compost at the Cherno and
you'll get access to all the source code
that I wrote here today as well as kind
of individual source code episode per
episode so definitely go help out
support the series they're huge thank
you to everyone who does that because
again we wouldn't be here without those
people so thank you so much that's
pretty much all there is about like that
dad that is a basic shader kind of
system that you can abstract out I mean
you can go really really crazy
really complicated with this and we will
definitely do that I promise in the game
engine series but for now for this
series that's really it
I mean if we jump back into our code
really quickly another thing we could do
and what we'll have to do is actually
kind of extend this whole uniform thing
so for example if we wanted to set a
single float so a1 F then we'd have to
write another function here that
actually just takes in our value like
this I'll go over here copy this
function call us at uniform 1f remove
all of these extra ones and this here as
well and you can see that we basically
just that that's it that's how we
implement this days and I could go
through an amplifier C's and integers
and all that kind of stuff right now but
I don't want to boy you guys you get the
point anyway and as we as we require
those set uniformed functions good
because as we start using those actual
values we'll have to kind of we'll just
implement them as we go along and out
that way it'll be nice and easy and we
don't have to spend like half now now
writing all the ones because that would
be really boring anyway next time I
think what else is there really too
abstract we have to deal with our render
at some point I don't know if that's
necessarily gonna be next time but it
looks like everything else is pretty
much abstract away I don't see any
OpenGL code here apart from our actual
draw call which is which we which will
be done by the renderer so let's do that
next time
let's go ahead and abstract our renderer
and actually create a renderer class
into which we can kind of parse all
these objects that we've created and
hopefully then it will render something
for us and then I think after that we
can probably move on to stuff like
textures and more exciting things so
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did you can hit that like
button to let me know and leave a
comment being like a series is awesome
or it's terrible do this instead or
whatever you want to write that's what
the comment section is for speak your
mind I will see you next time goodbye
[Music]